you
[Music]
see grapes
let's sail which leans on light tired of
islands a schooner beating of the
Caribbean for home could be Odysseus
home bound on the Aegean that father and
husbands longing under non sour grapes
is vaguely adulterer here in now
Sakura's name in every girl's outcry
this brings nobody peace the ancient war
between obsession and responsibility
will never finish and has been the same
for the sea Wondra or the one on show
now or wriggling on his sandals to walk
home since Troy side its last frame and
the blind giant boulder heave the trough
from whose groundswell the great hexam
it has come to the conclusions of
exhausted serve the classics can console
but not enough
[Music]